i think this is like 30 pounds of rice
you could probably make a cheesecake
with one of these this is the shrimp
mountain it's only crazy if it doesn't
work whoa
this is huge okay that's like 40 pounds
one two three whoa
hey guys i'm alvin and i love making
giant food we're back with tasty's
making a big season two everything's
bigger and better than before the food's
gonna be big the set is big i'm probably
gonna be a little bit bigger by the end
of the show but i'm very excited to show
you guys the giant food and the special
guests we have for this season today
i've invited in honeyeats a popular
mukbang artist on youtube who better to
make giant food for than someone who's
used to eating giant portions so let's
go meet her and see what she wants to
eat hi how are you good yeah are you
hungry so hungry all right good well i'm
a big fan of yours you are a
very popular artist on youtube right
where you upload videos of you eating
giant amounts of food what is that
called it's called mukbang and it's
derived from the words mongnen which
means eating and pang zong broadcast and
it originated in south korea why do you
think people enjoy watching other people
eat it's interesting to listen to other
people's life stories while they're
eating and sharing their love for food i
really want to cook for you today and i
want to make something giant that you
like to eat is there any food that you
would love for me to make today i would
love to see a giant version of a sushi
roll okay it's funny that is the number
one requested food i always get it's
just like please make a giant sushi roll
please make a giant sushi roll you're
really good at what you do on your
channel i've always been very curious
about like doing mukbang could you teach
me how to do it later if i can make the
giant boat for you yes of course i would
love to teach you okay well i'm very
excited for that so
i'm gonna get to work and i will see you
in a bit okay all right bye
[Music]
okay
we're gonna make a lot of sushi i want
to clarify before we get started this is
100 american sushi this is not japanese
sushi we have a lot of rice here that we
rinsed out and to cook sushi rice we're
going to dump this into a very big pot
and cook it with a lot of water let's
just do that oh that's cool
my grandpa used to say
you got to eat every grain of rice out
of your bowl because if you don't
every single grain of rice is one hair
you lose he's also
bald so i'm not sure why
he told me that so we're gonna cover
this with a lot of water
this is going to be brought to a boil
then i'm going to cover it and simmer it
on low for 20 minutes and
we're gonna have a lot of sushi rice
after that
all right it's been about 20 minutes
this rice should be cooked by now so
we're gonna take a look and see how it
is
whoa
that's a lot of rice
all right i'm gonna fluff this rice
okay
this is
it's a lot harder and a lot hotter than
it seems
steam is hot you guys be careful
okay so i'm gonna try to get
all this rice out of the pot into a bowl
let me see how
okay that's kind of heavy i might have
to call some help so i'm gonna go get
ryan one of our amazing culinary people
all right guys this is my buddy ryan
he's one of our amazing food people you
got it ryan's very strong which is why
he's doing it okay
all right how's your day going ryan
you know this is gonna be the highlight
is it giant red did you go to the gym
yet
uh no i think this is my workout yeah
you don't need to oh all right thanks
ryan yeah appreciate it hi this is
i think this is like 25 30 pounds of
rice
while this cools down i'm going to make
the sushi vinegar mixture to mix with
this rice so
first of all i want to give myself a
steam bath
i'll be right back
the rice is cooling we're going to make
our version of a sushi vinegar mixture
for our rice gotta go in with the rice
vinegar followed by the sugar the salt
and the vegetable oil so there's a lot
of rice and a lot of weight and the
reason we're adding vegetable oil is to
help it hopefully not stick too much
together because i think you'll be
adding a lot of pressure on the rice it
could cause the granules to burst and
just could cause the whole thing to
clump together too much
okay
this is the cold rice this vinegar
mixture is hot it's ready to go we're
going to put it into the rice so it
absorbs better than if it were cold
oh
i shouldn't have done that
all over the rice
don't do this if you're about to
go on a date afterwards we have a
nice little paddle to mix this rice in
so the goal of this you want to coat as
many grains of the rice as you can
ideally every single grain of rice is
coated with the vinegar mixture but
it's a lot of rice i'm not an expert at
this so
i think this is uh pretty much there i
did my best and
my arms might fall off afterwards so
we're gonna call it do you want to taste
it though
oh that's pretty good
i actually have never made a sushi robo
before so i want to practice doing a
normal sushi roll uh we're going to call
this part make it regular because i
don't want to mess with the big one so
we have our sushi mat the saran wrap is
gonna help make sure that it has an easy
release from the roll we're gonna take
nori which is seaweed the shiny side
stays down because the shiny side is
what's gonna be on the outside of the
roll a little bit of sushi rice
this is
pretty fun actually then we're going to
go with our toppings so we're going to
go down with a piece of
cucumber over here follow it up with
some cream cheese and then on top of
that smoked salmon that's looking pretty
good for fillings so the rolling what
you want to do is
kind of use the mat as a guide to roll
it without having to get your hand super
into it
okay that looks pretty good actually
let's clean stroke zone
it's actually not half bad alvin i want
to take a picture of it
this is my first ever sushi roll i think
i'm ready and we're gonna go make the
big one so
cheers
[Music]
we have a giant sushi mat this is
uh an invention made by our culinary
team who
really helped me out because i asked
them for a bamboo curtain we could not
find a bamboo curtain to roll the sushi
so they stitched together six regular
sushi mats i'm gonna go really big for
this one don't get stuck to yourself do
not dare get stuck to yourself i'm
thinking we can go like
make like a giant square this whole
thing is 18 inches i do want some space
on this side so minus one inch on both
sides
seven and a half
plus three minus one
i'm just gonna do it hold up
one okay cool and then we're gonna
try to seal the edges of the nori with
water so it's kind of like dumplings
where if you add water to the side it'll
get sticky and hopefully stick together
do this
one inch overlap
boom
okay so we have kind of a square
let's get rolling
okay we're just gonna
press it all down and
flat
okay so this is ready for toppings i'm
gonna get to it so let me see these
cucumbers start here
time for the cream cheese
we got bigger blocks this time
those are huge you could probably make a
cheesecake with one of these
so hopefully it doesn't fall apart all
right now for the smoked salmon
this is like a couple pounds trying to
keep this pile
together here we're going big
and we're not going home
wow okay um
that's a lot of stuff
i might have overfilled it but
we're gonna try to roll it okay this is
the nerve-wracking part i'm kind of
getting flashbacks to the 100 egg
omelette i made and we're going to try
to roll this carve a lot of tucking
going on
so we can go up we're going to need to
tuck it keep it tight alvin keep it
tight got to keep it tight so it won't
fall out
okay let's let's do that for now
it's like giving this guy like a little
massage i think that's a roll
do we get it
oh whoa look this is huge like the size
of a baby i'm gonna name you herbert hey
herbert you're a fat baby we're gonna
wrap up herbert in its blanket and throw
him in the fridge until he gets nice and
cold and hard and ready to be cut and
sleep well herbert
cool this is roll number two because
this is an inverted roll that means the
rice is going to go down first
that is
a lot of rice my strategy is to do the
the harder things on the bottom so we're
going to go in with the cucumber first
and then we're going to top it with the
crab this is imitation crab meat um i've
heard it's some sort of blend of fish
but
fooled me we're gonna go in with avocado
this is also kind of scary because the
there's no nori on the bottom it's just
the rice and there's a lot of stuff in
it
that was close all right alvin don't do
that again lift from the bottom and then
slowly
slowly
no come on
why
this is a problem child i'm gonna press
it down
and bring him back show him who's boss
i'm your father
i'll call you theodore he's the most uh
devious of the three chipmunks
whoa
i'm gonna finish by garnishing it with
some sesame because i think it's just a
nice touch theodore's done
moving on to roll number three we got
shrimp avocado and cucumber so let's
just get right to it i feel like i'm
getting faster at this as i move along
so that's a good sign i'm really into
these shrimp what do they taste like
oh it's good shrimp okay yeah it's
actually kind of looking precarious so i
want to stop right there this is the
shrimp mountain elevation
for shrimps
hmm
i put too much on guys oh wait that's
coming apart the shrimp mountain
is an avalanche
okay cool that's fine that's okay we're
gonna tuck
oh yeah look at that that's pretty cool
if you guys have been to the restaurants
there are rolls that have these patterns
on top and they kind of have these
different names um apparently there's a
role called the caterpillar roll because
there's like avocados fanned out and i
really want to try that out to see if i
can do it probably not going to do this
right
that's like kind of it let's see if we
can put that on there
okay that's a lot of avocado thing is on
in order to get it to form to the shape
of the roll you have to take this top
and then just like press it down hard
you need it to almost bind to the rice
all right well this is the one with the
shrimp i love it it's my favorite i'm
gonna name this one after my dad because
he's pretty cool so
what's up peter
wow never been able to have control over
my dad like that what a change
okay roll number four we got again
cucumbers cream cheese snack time
probably
it's pretty much set
nice another roll that's pretty popular
in the restaurants um they have salmon
on top you can't really just get sushi
grade salmon in such a large quantity
costco unfortunately didn't have it so
we're gonna go with smoked salmon
oh perfect it's like as if these things
were designed for
giant rolls made by an asian guy
that doesn't know how to make sushi
oh yes okay that was cool wow look at
that that's like exactly what it looks
like at the restaurants when they do the
salmon roll i gotta give this guy a name
really good looking on top
we'll call this guy
brad pitt
so
our wonderful art department got us a
beautiful wooden boat to serve the sushi
on i think it's amazing i think it looks
better than a plate okay we're gonna
unroll herbert he's been sleeping for a
bit
wow
look at that that's so cool
we're gonna
put this on
[Music]
let's go brad pitt i've seen videos
where they cut the rolls with stuff on
top and they cut it in the saran wrap so
it's easier to hold the top together
look at that that's so sick all right so
this is roll number three the problem
child the avocado okay i can never get
tired of these cross sections not gonna
lie look at all that shrimp each of
these has like a little like a
like a green comb over like a double
comb over air drop all right i have one
more roll this boat is at full capacity
we're gonna capsize if we keep going so
i'm just gonna cut it up and then
put on a nice little rectangle plate
okay so i cut up the last one it's
nicely plated because it won't fit on
this
okay that's like 40 it's like 40 pounds
and the last finishing touches
just a little bit of pickled ginger
clean your palate a little bit a tiny
little squeeze of wasabi
all right so this is pretty much done it
looks really cool i'm very happy with
the way it turned out and i'm excited
for honey to eat it so i'm gonna go
bring her in
all right
welcome back
thank you
yeah the sushi's in front of you so on
three one
two
three here's your sushi
whoa
whoa
this is like the biggest tissue roll
i've ever seen oh do you like it i love
it
this is a regular
sushi roll for scale this is actually my
first sushi roll i've ever made there's
some spicy mayo and some soy sauce for
dipping time to learn how to do mukbang
properly so we're gonna get some chairs
sit down and you're gonna teach me
[Music]
okay honey we're in a different sort of
setup can you explain to me why things
are set up this way so this is set up a
lot in front of us because it looks
bigger this way we want to show our
viewers oh yes everything so we have it
set up all around us so i have an intro
it goes hello my honeybees it's your
girl honey and so you're going to go
it's your boy oh wait do that again
again hello my honeybees it's your girl
honey it's your boy alvin and today
we're going to be eating 40 pounds of
sushi rolls so let's dig in because
they're so hungry i'm very hungry wow
that was great you have an intro my
intro is just like i'm alvin i like
giant food
first bite yeah first bite you guys eat
first
and for me i do this thing called honey
bite which is like your biggest bite you
can take okay so let's try that in three
one cheers
cheers
wow this is really good
i'm also going to drizzle some spicy
mayo on my sushi roll and i go cheers
little drizzle
drizzle drizzle drizzle drizzle girls
those dress wall and have like the most
sauce on my food that's a lot of sauce
this is like one of the craziest things
i've ever eaten i think
last bite
[Music]
you guys see that
well we're gonna probably keep eating
for the next
um how long would you take to finish
this finish this maybe like 40 minutes
to an hour are you kidding me
thank you for teaching me how to do
mukbang properly thank you guys so much
for watching i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please don't hit
the subscribe button if you haven't
already and to become a honeybee
and i'll see you guys in my next video
cheers
[Music]
you